Дедалі більше українців шукають у Німеччині прихисток від війни, розв'язаної Росією проти України.
На що треба зважати у питаннях житла і соціального захисту для біженців - у добірці DW.
Українцям не рекомендують подавати заявку про отримання класичного статусу біженця.
Це складна і тривала процедура, протягом якої заявники обмежені у пересуванні Німеччиною і не мають права працювати.
Натомість українським біженцям пропонують так званий тимчасовий захист.
Тривалість дії - один рік з можливістю подовження до трьох років.
Після прибуття до Німеччини потрібно зареєструватися в місцевій адміністрації за місцем проживання,
а тоді подати відповідні документи до відомства у справах іноземців.
Подавати документи можна одразу після прибуття до Німеччини.
Однак це необов'язково, оскільки тимчасові переселенці мають право перебувати тут 90 днів у рамках безвізового режиму.
У німецьких установах запевняють, що процедура для українців буде спрощена.
У деяких адміністраціях достатньо надіслати копію паспорта електронною поштою
і вказати адресу фактичного перебування у Німеччині.
За наявності, паспорт має бути закордонним, але якщо його немає - може бути й внутрішнім.
Після цього на вказану адресу надІйдуть анкети.
Заповнені документи слід передати до відділу реєстрації іноземців.
Слід зазначити, що процедура реєстрації українських біженців ще не до кінця відпрацьована.
Тому краще уточнити необхідні документи у місцевих адміністраціях.
Українці, які втекли від війни до Німеччини, можуть отримати дозвіл на роботу у відомствах зі справ іноземців.
Після отримання права на тимчасовий захист, біженці можуть звернутися по допомогу до Агенції з працевлаштування.
Варто пам'ятати, соціальна допомога біженцям виплачується лише безробітним -
це не поширюється на соціальні виплати на дітей.
Українцям радять утримуватися від сумнівних пропозицій роботи.
Не варто влаштовуватися на роботу без контракту, не оформивши дозвіл на роботу.
Українці, які отримали тимчасовий захист у ФРН, мають право на соціальну допомогу.
Ці кошти мають покривати витрати на харчування, одяг, здоров'я і базові побутові потреби.
Якщо людина проживає у притулку для біженців, значна частина цих потреб
може на розсуд соціальних служб покриватися наданням речової допомоги.
У такому випадку соціальна допомога становитиме: для дорослих залежно від форми співжиття -
від 170 до 212 євро на людину,
для дітей залежно від віку - від 156 до 161 євро.
Якщо тимчасові переселенці живуть не у гуртожитку або соціальному житлі для біженців,
а приміром, у помешканні, наданому, німецькими власниками,
то соціальна допомога дорослим становить від 294 до 367 євро на людину,
дітям - від 249 до 326 євро залежно від віку малечі.
Щоб отримати фінансову допомогу, слід подати заяву до відомства із соціальних питань при громаді проживання.
Медичне страхування біженці отримають після того, які офіційно зареєструються у відомстві із соціальних питань.
Воно покриватиме базові медичні потреби.
До того, як ця процедура буде завершена, у разі проблем із здоров'ям біженцям видаватимуть
цільові ваучери на медичні послуги, з якими можна звертатися до лікарів.
Для пошуку житла варто звернутися до місцевої влади за місцем прибуття.
Влада, як правило, веде облік житла, яке пропонують небайдужі громадяни.
Крім того, надаються ліжка у гуртожитках або інших місцях тимчасового розташування.
Це можуть бути спортзали шкіл або порожні зали для проведення культурних заходів.
Для оренди окремого житла соціальної допомоги не вистачить - через високі ціни на нерухомість у Німеччині.
У такому разі може допомогти, наприклад, оренда житла у небайдужих громадян,
які готові надавати його біженцям за нижчою ціною, яку готові покривати соціальні служби.
Німецькі правоохоронці просять бути обережними з пропозиціями житла й роботи,
які пропонують незнайомці на вокзалах.
Правоохоронні органи зафіксували спроби використання біженців
як нелегальної робочої сили в обмін на проживання.